why because anybody any man that pays a
couple of grand for that ain't got that
ain't got the Putter and you don't know
how to talk to a girl the girl just
wants to wear all that talk the
smooth talk that the men do and that's
what they're missing yeah so it's like
how do you how do they change their
personalities even even if even if you
get the suit and put them in VIP then
yeah you can't like one guy had talked
to me about world domination yeah he was
gonna like be a conqueror
he's gonna like conquer the world I was
like what I'll bet he's one of those
that go and dress up in army costumes
and playing fields at the end of the
week auntie I don't know you know you
should go to um
um is it erotica Expo they do that they
do an expo we're very Frank erotic and
they do classes in there